yellow welcome to this game it's 25
minutes 10 again Rapids chess-playing
Breck hmm yeah let's do a flank opening
something that I've played quite a bit
in tournament chess okay that's
interesting what he is doing is he's
just um handling it like it would be
colors reversed and like is intending to
go e five I don't want a king's indian
reversed but the groom felt reversed is
an entirely different thing so d4 i
actually got there is a pretty good line
for white the gruene felt here with the
tempo up very often we won't have a
let's say stand alone here opening where
something that really is a Greenfeld
reversed but we will probably transpose
to something i was a very weird sentence
we were transposed to something in this
case we will transpose to a tirage if he
takes with the pawn yes that's the
Queens gambit arash yeah maybe that is
what he wanted to play anyway but some
people really am yeah they stumble into
it by mistake and his thought there is a
bit it is a bit of a hint that maybe
he's not here willingly but okay you
never know people might take a couple of
seconds because they grab their cup of
coffee or whatnot eighty-five yeah well
III is an interesting sideline the move
a5 is some is I think not a particularly
great idea of course before was an idea
that a three introduced but that's not
the most um
important point of a three now he really
has that problem of being a gap being a
little bit weakened on the queenside and
I wonder in this particular situation
bishop f6 is definitely a move Bishop f6
Queen F 695 queen bee 297 this is a
well-known line without a three and and
a five plate the question is how does it
how does it differ hmm interesting
there's also rook see one that is also
making quite a bit of sense a possible
line especially of six Queen F 695 queen
bee 297 thats that's the point attacking
the rook on a eight and the bishop 106
rook 88 tempo on the Queen and then
Quincy one this is the way this is
normally unfolding and white has a
slight but very persistent advantage on
the other hand luke see one is
interesting as well so let's do that
it's a little bit more yeah that's the
somewhat more aggressive move let's say
that does not go into an endgame
immediately however Bishop f6 is
definitely a move that leads to some
advantage okay just retreats them yeah i
can go 90 form as one possibility and
just be satisfied with the fact that he
has weakened as Queen side that much I
think I'll do that some it's a simple
way to play but a good way block that IQ
peep okay you couldn't advance it anyway
do 2nite b5 and the pawn gets lost but
94 seems useful while White's position
is entirely standard let's say for this
i QP set up the moon 85 is la kind of
ugly weakening b5 b6 and so on this also
night takes is 6 in this position
sometimes capturing that Bishop for
weakening of blacks light squares mostly
but it's something that has to be
considered carefully if I want to take
on e6 yeah let's see what is doing if he
goes Queen to be six I probably will
just take on c6 a plane I day four nope
here's a number of less committal moves
like a rookie aid or something like that
but ok who create what really oh wow
that I don't really get am I not just
winning a pawn now with more than one
continuation fickle Bishop e7 we should
be 793 Roxy 397 ok it's good for white
but no porn there should be 793 bishop d
891 look fd1 yeah that that's so that's
pretty awful for black the question is
is the best move i also have night XD
for which also just wins a pawn I think
yeah hard to tell it's all pretty good
here you can play Bishop g5 of course
and then I go 90 x g5 Queen g5 90 x 6
and again that's a pawn 94 is a bit
mysterious as it is wrong due to a
number of things really ok so if I go
nite g5 he can play 94 maybe yeah that
that's also pretty dreadful but let's do
this and then take one g5 and then on c6
so for the pawn now you can almost
pre-move 95 but it's really no no need
to be in any hurry here so I've one upon
but um it's not um yeah it's not super
easy to win I mean ok it's not like it's
not super difficult either but it's
still very easy busily imaginable that
um white is maybe losing vporn somehow
because of the open B file and we get
like four against three at the end which
will be very often a draw yeah like a
deep on the exchange versus a 3 NB to
that can easily happen under some
circumstances and then now then the
technical task is really really
substantial so rupee am as imagined um
can I really cannot give him that pawn
most obvious move is Queen deform I
wonder if there's something something
I'm better also Roxy to rock d2 might be
a maneuver 24 looks very normal what
does this move then Queen f6 maybe I'll
take Roxy to them it's not it's not that
easy it really isn't let's think here is
there some better way to play this for
example is b3 a move probably not let's
go here
hmm maybe just a rock c5 in Bishop t5
coming up
because rook be three yeah maybe even
rook be six then okay h6e his son a bit
concerned about them back rank
understandably so yeah okay I'm going
for that tip on maybe you can go Queen
f6 now that was a bit of a superficial
move anyway if he goes Queen f6 I can
take a look-see to anyway he is he's got
an aged six for free but compared to
Queen f6 of 18 but well that's not the
end of the world yeah someone posted a
comment in an earlier video with the
time control what I did to ruin my
rating yeah with 1,900 yeah it's just
that we start with 1600 in that new poor
and um yeah I've won every single game
that I played in it but it just takes a
while until rating gets to it gets to
that though those higher levels it's
simply a matter of time okay so um i
wonder if i should play before here i
think i should actually let's do that so
that i can be sure that it's not putting
pressure on that be porn from b8 take it
i'll have a big porn that is rather
dangerous and if he takes on c5 i can
also even take with that phone and get a
protected that's wrong not a protected
passer but a nice advanced pawn yeah
okay I don't need to remove them tho
those primos if I pre-move that it
always looks a bit a bit back here so
I'm not going to pretty move yep got not
good enough time yeah I mean I think you
should take on before and trade trade
this pair of pawns it was important to
note that the move rook f2c one instead
yeah if I would have gone roop f2c one
then he had quinsy one oops and I'm
losing so you can always blend that you
came away hardly any position where ya
playing something stupid and losing it
is impossible mm-hmm ok I definitely
need something to drink so sorry for the
drinking noises it's just too too
haughty and Germany at the mode
guy is taking a while yeah okay the
position is not easy to play I
understand but probably a text before
yeah display it anyway so take him so
I've got them the B porn as an asset I
couldn't take on g5 and maybe I could
have taken on d5 actually huh Bishop g5
Bishop b5 rook 25 is just the second
pawn and Bishop b5 I was thinking rook
takes c5 would be good for black but I
could have taken a eight then not
interesting so I could have taken the
pawn instead of before I was a sloppy
play but ok I'll before it's not bad in
itself it's just that if the other move
is better I should have preferred that
any way I can always go in the next move
okay he takes it um yeah with what yeah
probably with the pawn
just looks more harmonious and I've got
your key one coming up with more
pressure on d5 could the combined
pressure on d5 enter and the sea pawn
should be quite quite substantial in
fact if I have worked you one next let's
say he goes rook c8 rook do you want
okay Queenie 7 you might might yeah I
play place that maybe yeah anyway that's
um I don't need to very much about those
details I have a couple of useful moves
that I can play like III for example
then Luke see one yeah okay he's trying
to activate that rook I wonder if Brooke
a one is the move but people probably
know we cannot take it too because of
ruka a check and 23 a still queer okay
one looks weird taking that looks
strange shouldn't do that um gal III is
the most normal continuation maybe it's
God looks it to them
hmm look see two might fields feels a
bit bit annoying that move really how
interesting
huh let's see how to play that you three
look see two I don't see a great move
after that I mean okay I'm not in
trouble or anything but it's it's really
helpful for him that he's got if we get
some behind the pie okay let's check
okay one for once Luke a one-take sticks
and Queen d2 that was what brought me a
little bit but I have a head just have a
three right III and queen d for next
okay not Queen deform be sure everyone
yeah that's not good rupee a one is not
helping taking and print to a son it's a
problem I can go Bishop f3 but I don't
like it that that just doesn't feel
right so let's check III Roxy to do I
have anything else that I can play
hmm really not entirely sure what the
best weapon way is here from a technical
point of view
I wonder if F 4 is a move or is that
just weakening uselessly
f was very much weakening queen age 5 or
something now it's not a good idea so
what else is them
can play I that's also bad hmm
after e3 rooks eat we s Queenie 7 that
that's really a really a problem
amazingly enough okay maybe no that's
also not going to work hmm
okay maybe check okay one again at least
that prevents Roxy tool takes takes
Queen d2 so my background is a week
that's a problem like if I go III then
you place Quincy to have no means of
protecting that porn conveniently in
fact if I protected he will check me on
the back rank and that's not going to
end well
rope d1 maybe just attacking that pawn
that is that's him that doesn't feel
right doesn't feel right at all rookie
to look the one low key to Bishop 25 to
55 Queen if I lucky one check this kind
of crap nope that is not good at all not
good at all okay
I don't see a good continuation
amazingly enough maybe a fire that's a
very radical solution to the whole thing
I'm just going to look at it too
okay I'm playing that now it took took
ages for that move seven minutes that's
crazy oh my okay it's also a bit early
in the day and it looks weird to trade
off his weakness but after takes Bishop
takes rook Seto is prevented and Massey
pawn can be pushed to c6 being protected
by the g2 bishop I'm worried about rooty
to those kind of moves but I thought
that Quincy three queen before should be
okay Quincy three might have tea for
them
the other move before that wasn't so
precise but it wasn't and maybe with
hindsight maybe be takes maybe the other
move was stronger huh yeah I played a
bit a bit too quickly maybe in the UM
earlier them allowing a bit too much
plane he also has some bishop age three
yeah rocky to marry but then Quincy
three looks okay
any other moussaka bishop page 3 of
course I can move the rook or play
Bishop g2 nachdi one is some looks a bit
more attractive as it immediately
threatens Queen the aid winning now I
guess so
and rooty tooty Quincy three then what
then Bishop a three maybe so where will
I have to have to keep my pawn protected
so choice is somewhat limited see three
or before I rc3 looks looks a bit more
normal that same
yeah good resistance that he's putting
up yeah probably let before secret I
could have taken d 5 that was probably
the the real way the good way to do it
am i threatening f4 in this position my
not really has got quindi aid protecting
that rook always good to check for those
liabilities sometimes they would be very
effective using the mummy yes oh yeah
yes the question Bishop g2 are moving
the rook if i move the rook f2 is a bit
vulnerable on the other hand how is he
attacking it how is he supposed to
attack that porn I don't really see a
second idea is maybe c6 actually ok no
no c6 bishop at once e7 he can drop back
to h 30 Essex so it's not working and
this should be too I don't like because
after the capture he has got 25 second
but that feels wrong it really feels
wrong the question is do i go to e 1 or
2 c1
I think Iman his his rook is somewhat
its active but also some sort of
liability if I go to see one I don't
like to be in that Queens diagonal so
that there might be some tactics of my
queen moves on the other end on you
wanted is unprotected which is also not
entirely idea yeah my hunch says rupee
one
especially one age three is some really
annoying them but I think Bishop g2
didn't help I just have to be constantly
aware of the week back rank so I have to
make sure that there's no tactic with
some check down yeah for for instance if
I cannot not that as you're working and
any any check on the back ranked by a
rock or queen would be would be fatal k
goes back what is the idea here look to
you one maybe
maybe just roped in one but i was
thinking c6 should be fine here right c6
what is the big IDM at 24 why
okay um is there anything else that I
can do here he's also having some back
rank issues with the bishop recovering
age seven I move like let's a bishop see
to threaten screen txt to but I don't
really know this making much sense so I
can't push that
because route 1 my work only one is not
hanging or anything it's protected so I
don't really have any a big issue there
look the one I can all I can play like
Bishop e3 that same to almost no that's
not forcing the rope treaty as Rupert
III yeah anyway let's see if he is
playing that to move or not
c7 is pretty big bitty pretty big threat
so he has to react in some way I think
route d1 is very likely to happen hmm
what exactly is my name if I go bishop
as three here in he has roped III that's
quite a big issue home
yep he went for that John that's true
one Bishop f3 that's rookie three very
embarrassing okay Bishop c2 maybe takes
on you one Queenie one and always have
picture before and can regroup it's not
the greatest technical display over here
really not
I'm not quite sure what else I can do I
don't have many moves away double him
cannot take on the one cannot move the
rook queen also does it have any
sensible moves they'll probably Bishop
c2 almost forcing that trade and then I
always have Bishop before to cover that
cover that pawn candle very team that
Bishop c220 for a move like that I have
group texts Eamon Quinn c3 rock yet made
ok
it's a slightly precarious situation
ready with the bishops II to Queen d5
maybe yeah that's that's true I also i
don't have um or do I have that pusher
h7 statim movement that it looks
entirely weird TX Quincy to check
well that's almost working but on Bishop
h7 can go King a jade and the whole
thing didn't really need too much
ah not quite sure what I should play
really not sure bishop said 225
I don't have many moves that's really
really a big problem i'm running out of
sensible options i can maybe what can I
do is there something else
a possible queen d 4 is this is really
really an issue
hmm
um I don't see a move wow I really
spoiled that stuff I'm AFC 744 drawing
but it's not exactly what you want after
you we're basically winning out of the
opening boom that's this bad is there
any other idea Bishop f3 again let's
check it that was my original intention
is root T 3 root T 3 there's some way to
sac that bishop rook f3 Quincy five rook
f3c seven
sweet c 7
Bishop f3 rock t three
Quincy five look f3c seven a queen ch I
have Queen Elsa Quincy six that will
action that will probably win maybe see
some windy so yeah let's draw
stay another other Queen moves that
might be of interest
not really who is there move that I have
not considered yet at all queen bee for
for example instead of move Queen before
I it's already a bit risky simply
because of them the time situation to
consider playing on Queen B form
before I said move looks at be eight so
that blacks Queen cannot easily move on
the other hand is not quite clear what
the queen is doing on before maybe
threatening Bishop f3 set a move Queen
before I'll check windy for Queen B 826
maybe
quindi six now then I've got no I don't
have that Queen before Queen d6 of
course I can take it I can not take you
1 26 is really annoying I don't see a
move after that hmm so I cannot play
Queen before where do we have to play c7
really am I blind or what maybe I am
maybe I am I don't see how to continue I
feel that maybe there is something what
I don't see it I really don't see it
Bishop c2 as Queen d5 that that's that's
really
okay i have two places 7i think come on
i only have one minute left and that's
the draw of course can just take you 1
takes you seven wow that's really really
really bad check spoiling that
completely winning position technically
winning gym but really really really all
folium
yeah it's a complete draw what's but hmm
really awkward check anything I can hope
for now probably not
you let me I can gain some space on the
kingside didn't see what happens g4 h4
trying to play for a loss always
possible and awkward gym then I rotate
what I mean maybe I'm just completely
blind and and didn't see didn't see the
right continuations but but I really I
really didn't see anything great there
yeah well now I can I can maybe just
offer draw here and end it here it's
very difficult to imagine not someone
making a mistake here what there anyway
can play a couple of moose
a queen f6 is the easiest check that's
of course also fine you can go with the
queen of the first rank threatening
checks from the back
yep also also fine of course um so any
there anything i can i can try at least
I mean also don't want to lose them that
would be even more embarrassing each
five I know it's probably a draw anyway
hmm pretty wonder what what what exactly
did I do wrong
yeah so going back now and he will check
me on the second I guess then we can
agree a draw yeah maybe really that
Bishop takes to find that I could have
taken that porn at one point and they're
just played before a bit too I was
superficially played really
check
doesn't really matter i always have a
hard time to accept that it's going to
be a draw but yeah it's really the case
as long as he I mean many can play
whatever he wishes and draw but if he
just keeps the Queen on that diagonal
it's very difficult very difficult for
me to to do anything
check sometimes you can tempt the other
guy to play on and by letting your own
clock run down I have used that strategy
I'm very rare occasions but I don't know
if it's a great idea the gay I'm can
play here and cover happy one AG one and
maybe I for next anyway it's it's of
course a draw so f for am i risking
anything with that move I don't think so
its of course it's no real winning tribe
but um there's nothing particularly
wrong with it
check yeah so Queen takes I guess who
King Texas really weird so let's take
with this now I can go Quincy three
check
check Joe let's go him it's it's even
though twin traders of course a draw but
at least there I am have some very good
okay has to be very suicidal to screw it
up check so probably not happening we
Came step him
mmm
check
check
champ the only thing I have to really
check for check check for that I'm
running in some kind of self media
sometimes you can do that with the
increase in caves so yeah like King age
for Queen H to check Queen h3 that
already looks like a little bit that
looks like a weird way to do it
so anything else I can justifiably tribe
can run around a little bit with the
king but that's not helping at all check
I'm sorry for dragging this on a little
bit but I have always have a hard time
to to ya to accept that I'm not going to
win the game after he had such a good
position there's almost no way for him
to screw it up Jenny f6 would be also a
very simple solution just trade queens
but somehow he's not doing that check of
course he can just check this really
know there's nothing wrong with it
but just training is completely
completely fine check yeah to f5 these
are the kind of stunts that sometimes
will will lose you the game currently I
don't see why it should lose but it's
also really not trying for a win check
yang prominent member fastforward this
Quincy 30 check it's probably perpetual
check somewhere
it takes it now we can go king f6 ng5
that that's really a child that's a
total draw but he's not doing that I
mean there's no need he has all the
checks but anyway check
check
I think you just has to press the draw
button to claim the threefold somehow he
doesn't do it
check
queen f6 of course it's a wide range
wide range of drawers
I really could have traded Queens a ton
of times and then the game would be over
already that's somehow a reason why i
miss our continuing because i don't get
why it didn't exchange Queens maybe he
hopes that I'm killing myself which I
tend to do sometimes but it's a bit
difficult to mention here jack how to
how to do that Queen g3 ads and it's
towards an immediate draw Queen h1 and
so on check
this g5 a move forward you can check me
on h1 doesn't doesn't help at all
rawr a third it's tiny pointless for a
long time really important as I said I
sometimes have a hard time to accept us
he's declining that that's funny
ok
g5 may be something I could it's going
to check on f1 time morning I can I can
do that I think Queen f1 check Kim's you
form
well it's still a total row nothing
really nothing happening Queen f1 check
I can also go to age to wear that after
that she doesn't have her check
check
22 King edge for it is a draw and stays
stays the draw check
check
check
check
check ya know he's forcing that draw I
cannot go to a five I mean I can but
it's kind of pointless 25 check it's not
pressing the trop night jack I don't get
it ok anyway I've drawn so ah yeah that
was unnecessarily long of course I
should have maybe just considered the
draw meconium yeah I was just a bit too
disappointed to be honest I mean not 94
is just yeah just losing actually that
didn't I didn't didn't convert that just
bad okay i form a 5pm maybe that's maybe
the most forceful but I didn't like to
read my position there it's probably
winning the pond a bit okay this is not
bad now before yeah maybe I could have
taken here right Roxy 5 i'm sorry Roxy
five Bishop here it's got that one it's
two pawns I mean okay I should have seen
it now and I can still decide to not
play it but i only saw that idea here
and so yeah so if all is actually the
best move or no no the engine gives f
form i already wonder around here 23
Queen the Queen edge here maybe really
the rook move I didn't see six Queen f3
is stronger but i really wonder is there
nothing that I can do here Queen III
okay we need three Queenie Hawkwind here
and this I can still continue and I
didn't yet at the end I got too nervous
inflate c7 I mean too nervous I spent
like 10 minutes yeah so and and really
couldn't come up with anything anything
decent Queen III yeah and maybe that's
the only move I was thinking this one
but then queen d 6 losses for me Bishop
f3 rock d 3 or then c7 actually wins oh
why did I see that oh that sets
embarrassing but he has this movement
wins so I was right with the assessment
is not with the line I thought this move
but then queen d 5 as a huge issue Jim
maybe yes really only that Queen III
move I don't really see him I mean luck
here that is also just to draw I have to
play that I don't know I didn't didn't
cross my mind that is possible really
hmm yeah we can after the chat we're
just talking about the check complete
draw check check check check check check
yeah chain as i mentioned chat with yet
some check across societies to just try
it the queen check check Mike here's our
example Jack check their wish I mean
here in this case if you change takes he
gets here and at the end now will win
that poem which is still of course draw
so giant was just a bad technical plane
yeah I already felt very irritated here
with that with that group move I always
wanted to do this but Roxy to I mean
half that is not it's just not okay I
mean I'm losing their pawn and that
already deeply irritated me now I mean
it's not an objective problem as if or
is good for white but it now gets some
have to calculate more and here this
chest also not that grade gym
yeah as I said here white can also go
for that so be better for me but I
wanted to play whoopsie one thats its
also i mean it had led to a great
position and that you for just is it was
a big mistake but i should i should
maybe just do this I am I was a bit um I
was too sloppy in that in that phase of
the game basically thinking I that it
winds itself but it really didn't it's
not a mistake but they're here already
it's a bit that requires precision and
he may be look a one maybe look a one I
didn't think about rook e1 I have ever
very had a very very bad candidate move
from um approach here i was thinking
about c 10 t 1 x minus k1 okay one is
just strong with the idea of playing
this I probably wins very easily Jim
now and here the comp suggest Queen f3
that's probably a good idea covering
this and planning c6 yeah that was my
original intention was Bishop f3 in that
position and only later saw Brooke t3
which was not working but Queen III was
so a very sloppy play him yeah okay i
hope you enjoyed that game it wasn't
very thrilling one and in terribly long
video at the end on hope you
fast-forward through the last 30 votes
or so thanks for watching